Ich habe euch letzte Woche darum
gebeten, mir Kommentare oder Fragen
zur Reportage "Meine Beziehung
zu meiner Vulva" zu schicken.
Ich bin überwältigt
von den vielen positiven Feedbacks,
die ich erhalten habe.
Das erfreut mein Herz extrem.
Ich hätte das nie gedacht.
Wir haben wirklich mit vielen
negativen Kommentaren gerechnet.
Wir hatten anfangs den Aufruf
auf unserem YouTube-Community-Tab
gestartet
und dort
waren die Reaktionen fifty-fifty.
Aber dass jetzt
so viel Wärme, so viel Verständnis
und so viele positive Kommentare zu-
rückgekommen sind, freut mich extrem.
Ein Kommentar,
der mir extrem aus dem Herzen sprach,
war der von NB:
Oder der von kA:
Es ist extrem schön,
solche Kommentare zu lesen.
Es kamen v.a.
auch Kommentare von Männern,
was mich extrem freute.
Von Männern, die sagten,
sie seien mir dankbar dafür,
dass ich das Thema aufgenommen habe.
Sie sagten,
dass sie das nicht wussten
oder dass so in ihrer Beziehung
vieles klar werde.
Ein Kommentar
hat mich besonders berührt.
Er kommt von Harry Haller:
Es ist wahnsinnig schön,
wenn auch diese Generationen
von diesem Film berührt wurden.
Es gibt natürlich auch Reaktionen,
die fanden,
das sei ihnen
viel zu persönlich und zu intim
und sie in der Öffentlichkeit
nicht darüber sprechen würden.
Jemand hat Folgendes geschrieben:
Mir ist aufgefallen,
dass wir Menschen mit einer Vulva
unsere Vulva in unserem Alltag
nur sehr, sehr selten berühren.
Wenn ein Mensch mit einem Penis
auf die Toilette geht,
hält er ihn schon sieben-
bis achtmal pro Tag in der Hand.
Es ist absolut selbstverständlich.
Bei uns
ist immer ein Papier dazwischen.
Auch wenn wir uns
vor den Spiegel stellen,
sehen wir unsere Vulva
eigentlich nicht direkt.
Es braucht viel Bewusstsein
und einen bewussten Entscheid
von uns,
unsere Vulva überhaupt anzusehen
oder zu berühren.
Ich glaube,
dieser Unterschied führt dazu,
dass es einfach für Männer ...
... bzw. für Menschen mit einem Penis
viel selbstverständlicher ist,
dieses Körperteil anzunehmen.
Alva v. hat geschrieben:
Das Thema ist eigentlich entstanden,
weil ich ursprünglich
für eine andere Sendung
verschiedene Sexualtherapieformen
recherchiert habe.
Dabei fiel mir auf, dass ich eigent-
lich die Kundin von all dem bin -
dass es mich selber
ja auch interessiert,
weil es für mich
schon lange ein Thema ist:
meine Sexualität,
welche Blockaden habe ich usw.
Ich kam dann auf die Idee,
dass i c h vielleicht ...
... eine Sendung dazu machen muss.
Ich ging damit zu Ilona
und sie hat mich mit ihrem Wesen
und ihrer Empathie darin bestärkt,
dass ich in ihr eine wahnsinnig star-
ke Partnerin an meiner Seite habe,
die mich unterstützt,
mir viel Raum lässt
und der ich wirklich vertrauen kann.
So kamen wir auf dieses Thema.
Wir wollten
meine Geschichte aufarbeiten.
Ich sollte also
die Protagonistin werden.
Das kostete mich anfangs
wirklich Überwindung und Mut.
Ich musste den Rahmen
für mich abstecken:
Was will ich erzählen?
Wie weit will ich gehen?
Denn schlussendlich
exponierte ich mich extrem.
Alle wissen jetzt, wie es um meine
Vulva und meine Sexualität steht.
Aber ich war schon immer
eine eher mutige Person.
Ich exponiere mich gerne.
Und es ist mir sehr wichtig,
dass ich einen Impact haben kann.
Ich wollte dadurch
andere Menschen erreichen
und ein Verständnis dafür schaffen.
Ich bin unglaublich froh,
dass wir das gemacht haben.
Eine weitere Frage:
Yoni stammt aus dem Tantrischen.
Es ist ein tantrischer Begriff.
Er stammt aus Indien
und ist ein Sanskritwort.
Das Schöne an diesem Begriff ist,
dass er das ganze weibliche
Geschlechtsorgan ablichtet.
Er inkludiert die Vulva,
die Vagina, die Klitoris,
die Eierstöcke und die Gebärmutter.
Im deutschen Sprachraum
existiert eigentlich kein Wort,
das für das Ganze steht.
Tantra, Yoga und die indischen Lehren
sind heute ein fixer Bestandteil
unserer Gesellschaft.
Und ich glaube,
darum wird der Begriff Yoni
heute auch häufiger verwendet.
Ganz schön ist,
dass Yoni auch Mutterschoss heisst -
dort, wo alles Leben entsteht.
Ein Mann fragt:
Dass es für dich
schwierig nachzuvollziehen ist,
wie ich mich fühle,
ist mir absolut klar.
Du hast nicht geboren.
Als Mann hat man wahrscheinlich
auch eine andere Beziehung
zu seinem Geschlechtsorgan.
Ich glaube aber nicht,
dass es eine Verkopfung ist.
Es ist ein Gefühl, das uns
über Generationen weitergegeben wird.
Meine Grossmutter z.B.
durfte oder wollte garantiert
nicht über ihre Sexualität sprechen.
Das war damals ein extremes Tabu -
und das
nur zwei Generationen vor mir.
Sieht man sich die heutige Zeit an:
Jedes Kind malt mal einen Penis
an eine Hauswand.
Aber die Vulva
ist absolut unterrepräsentiert.
Ich glaube auch,
dass Kinder nicht einmal wissen,
wie eine Vulva aussieht.
Es geht dann weiter,
dass das Wort Penis vielen Leuten
einfach über die Lippen rutscht.
Wenn man aber
über "das da unten" spricht,
was ja eben das Problem ist,
fallen die Wörter Vulva und Vagina
vielen Menschen schwer.
Auch Menschen mit einer Vulva.
Das zeigt mir auch, dass die Vulva
in unserer Gesellschaft noch nicht
Normalitätsstatus erreicht hat.
Damarisli hat einen für mich
wichtigen Kommentar geschrieben:
Ich bin wahnsinnig dankbar
für diesen Kommentar.
Ich habe nämlich schon gehandelt:
Ich habe das Krankenhaus
gestern angerufen
und mit der leitenden Hebamme
gesprochen.
Ich fragte sie,
ob sie diese Gespräche anbieten.
Sie sagte: "Natürlich."
Ich habe kurz meine Krankenakte
bzw. den Geburtsbericht
mit ihr angeschaut.
Sie hat mir
einzelne Punkte bestätigt:
Es war eine sehr lange Geburt,
es gab einen Geburtsstillstand ...
Sie sagte,
es sei wirklich, wirklich wichtig,
dass ich das Thema noch einmal
mit einer Hebamme anschaue.
Sie sagte auch, dass sehr viele
Frauen zurück ins Spital kämen,
teils auch zehn Jahre später noch.
Es braucht einfach Zeit,
bis man bereit ist,
das Ganze wieder zu thematisieren
und anzuschauen.
Ich habe einen Termin
mit der Hebamme,
die mir damals
bei der Geburt geholfen hat.
Es hat mir extrem geholfen,
dass ich diesen Anruf getätigt habe.
Ich weiss jetzt,
dass ich das Ganze in zwei Wochen
noch mal anschauen kann.
Vielleicht gibt mir das
etwas mehr Klarheit.
Es kam noch ein Kommentar
von einem Mann:
Wie ihr gesehen habt, haben sie
auch mich zu Tränen gerührt.
Was David mir
am Schluss dieser Reportage sagte,
hatte er mir so noch nie gesagt.
Das war extrem schön.
Wir haben im Vorfeld
natürlich viel darüber gesprochen,
aber diese Reportage hat uns
noch viel näher zusammengebracht.
Wir mussten natürlich viel intensiver
über die Thematik sprechen.
Ich musste ja handeln.
Ich musste in diese Workshops gehen
und über das Erlebte sprechen.
Das zeigte mir auch,
dass es sehr wichtig ist,
einen unterstützenden Partner
oder eine unterstützende Partnerin
zu haben, der oder die
euch auf diesem Weg begleitet,
denn man sitzt im selben Boot.
Tom Baumann fragt:
Das ist ein sehr guter Input.
Ein Trauma ist etwas,
das mit dem Körper passiert,
worüber du keine Kontrolle mehr hast
und womit
deine Bewältigungsmechanismen
nicht mehr umgehen können.
Das löst sehr viel aus.
Vieles davon ist sicher
in meinem Unterbewusstsein verankert.
Mein Plan ist, das Ganze in Zukunft
in einer Sexual- oder Gesprächs-
therapie weiter zu betrachten -
als Ergänzung
zu den Workshops und Seminaren,
die ich besucht habe
und weiterhin besuchen werde.
Denn das hat mir auch gezeigt,
dass es eine traumatische Geburt war,
aber dass
noch viel anderes mitspielt,
das vielleicht in meiner Kindheit
oder auf meinem Lebensweg
passiert ist,
dass es Situationen gab, die das
Ganze schlussendlich kanalisierten
und zu dieser Blockade führten.
Diese Frage
habe ich mir schon lange gestellt.
Ich möchte einfach ...
... eine Beziehung
zu meiner Vulva haben,
in der ich sagen kann:
"Hey, girl, you're good."
"Ich mag dich. Du gehörst zu mir."
"Du bist Teil von mir.
Ich finde dich megacool."
"Ich nehme dich an, wie du bist.
Du gehörst zu mir."
Momentan fühle ich mich so,
als wäre ich, Susan, hier
und meine Vulva
würde irgendwo hier rumschwimmen.
Es wurde mir bewusst,
dass es eigentlich ...
Ich habe ein Problem
mit meiner Vulva,
aber ich muss ihr vielleicht
auch ganz viel Trost ...
... spenden und sie wieder annehmen.
Denn sie hat Unglaubliches geleistet,
wenn ich an die Geburt denke.
Sie hat sich geöffnet,
sie hat ein Kind zur Welt gebracht,
sie hat sich komplett zerrissen ...
Es muss eigentlich
eine Beziehung entstehen,
in der wir miteinander kommunizieren
und in der ich sie nicht ablehne,
sondern sie annehme ...
... und tröste,
damit wir beide wieder ...
... eine versöhnliche Beziehung
haben können.
Eine Beziehung,
in der wir beide als starke Löwinnen
in der Welt stehen können.
Das war's. Vielen Dank
für eure Worte und euren Support.
Ihr könnt weiterhin kommentieren.
Ich beantworte gerne alles für euch,
auch in Zukunft.
Abonniert doch den Kanal, wenn ihr
noch mehr "Rec."-Folgen sehen wollt.